[Music]
hey you guys
happy sunday yeah tom is a leather daddy
somebody already said
yeah they're gonna have to say that
anyway uh i can't figure what the [ __ ]
wrong with the ice maker
driving me [ __ ] crazy i'm sorry last
time i just put a new filter in and
it worked again so but you know [ __ ]
that filter is brand new i don't know
what it's doing
why it's doing that it's got the little
thing and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
frustrating frustrating machines
machines yeah yeah an ice maker ice
maker in the refrigerator door
freezer door right that sucks
intermittent we need to get something to
get my ice man
well we need to get do we have any ice
cube trays anyway no
no we don't have any maybe we should
just go into the dollar store and get
some there's no room for ice cube trays
anyway that's true there's too much crap
in there what's in the seven there scott
said maybe it's a clogged line
maybe it might be uh but i don't know
how to unclog one
i don't either right and still the
water's still coming out just the um
it's not making ice but it's not making
ice though yeah revolt of the machines
yeah it's gonna be this
yeah so uh today kind of tired went out
last night
tom said this morning he's like man
we're getting too old to run around with
these
with these young kids yeah even
even on performance-enhancing drugs
i do recover a lot faster though um
yeah i can i before i wouldn't even want
to go looking at funk dance yet
yeah that's true yeah because for a long
time you were just kind of like
yeah you're all cranky yeah still cranky
yeah he's fussy
that's fussy last night man i was coming
out of the damn house and trying to go
in between all the cars because they're
having a party next door and dude
[ __ ] ran right in there and [ __ ]
tried to [ __ ] block me he wouldn't
let me out i jumped out of the [ __ ]
car
and went up to his window i was getting
ready to fight the [ __ ] right
he was from some country i don't know
what country he was from
but sound middle eastern or something
was i was like
dude what do you [ __ ] do listen come
on fight me and he says oh i'm going
he left yeah he wouldn't come fighting
he goes
he's a fat little man you know
yeah yeah
yeah i went back on that injection
see that's what i have to keep him from
getting in trouble it's like
you're gonna get arrested no no no it's
because
because you're going around like it's
because of that damn blood test they
made me go off of it yeah
all right for for a while you got to
clean this clear the system out and then
i went back on it
and then i snuck a little extra because
i was just like
man i need more it was kind of a little
bit addictive you know they say once you
go on it you never want to come off but
i um yeah man that was the weird some
weird [ __ ] i'ma beat this motherfucker's
ass
yeah and i was just like please she's in
there going oh
i was like look i just want to go out
and have a good time it's saturday it's
not like getting a fight before you even
get out of the [ __ ] driveway it's all
right he
he didn't want to fight well it's a good
thing he's like
yo he's my age he was my age you know he
he's like i'm not gonna fight this dude
in the middle of [ __ ] street
neighborhood where we live i was like
that's right i'm gonna get ghetto as
[ __ ] all the neighbors are gonna see
all the neighbors are gonna [ __ ] see
let's try to do that
found an ear cleaning machine in her
hair
[Laughter]
oh my god how do you come up with these
every you guys are so funny man you guys
are so
you're digging a machine it's not an ear
cleaning machine it's your digging
machine
you just do it it's clean it does clean
it but he's just with my ear digging
machine
and he called it he also called it an
ear dick and an ear digging mechanism
i thought he said an ear [ __ ]
so yeah we're talking about today uh the
movie splice
yeah which uh tom really digs this movie
i actually really
dig this movie too the last time we
watched it we watched it a couple days
ago and i kept like falling asleep
because i was super tired but i've seen
it before
so it's not like i'm just like talking
on my ass and i haven't seen it i
mentioned this i saw a movie when it
came out
didn't see it in the theater though you
know i think yeah i don't think i saw
this little
theater i guess it had been out for
maybe a year or so back in those days
came out in 2009.
yeah i probably saw it in 2010 yeah it
was newish when i saw it
and i liked it and then i said something
about it the other day and sandra went
she saw it
you know sandra with her ear digging
machine she saw it
and she went back and says yeah it was a
good movie so i had to revisit it
went see if it held up it held up it
held up it's a good movie
it's the same guy the guy that directed
it vincenzo natalie he's
uh the same guy that did cube which is
also really good he's done other ones
too but i think cube is probably his
best known one
other than this one um and i think a
guillermo
guillermo del toro was even a uh
producer on this like an executive
producer i feel like
this movie is
kind of [ __ ] up it's a little bit
cronenbergian
i feel like it kind of goes in like a
sort of cronenbergian kind of direction
a little
bit um and i like that they
got really good actors meaning because
i've always really liked adrian brody
he's great in it and uh what's her face
uh
sarah paulie she was great in the dawn
of the dead remake
and so these two are okay so i have to
do this before i
forget i was watching a review of this
earlier
and i was reading the comments like on
youtube
and somebody said uh moral of the story
don't bang your science project yeah and
then the person underneath that
said but my baking soda volcano really
seemed to enjoy it though
and i laughed and laughed and laughed so
i didn't like write that joke but i was
just kind of like i just thought under a
thing and it just made me laugh really
hard so i thought i would mention it
but uh but yeah so so these two play are
they married or no they're just a
boyfriend girlfriend
um because they have different last
names yeah i don't think they were
married
i love that they named his first name as
clive and her first name is elsa
which that's colin clive and elsa
lanchester that's who they're
referencing there from frankenstein
bride of frankenstein
uh so you know in case you didn't know i
didn't see any any of the reviews i saw
none of them mentioned that
i'm like did they they don't know maybe
they didn't realize
yeah i mean i thought it was pretty
obvious yeah but you're a nerd
you read all that [ __ ] nerd
nerd pick right up on that oh yeah yeah
yeah i read that book
you know but uh he's always making fun
of him
i'm proud of my nerdiness i'm just
teasing i'm proud of my number
teasing but uh yeah i didn't catch it
that's why she watches that mst you know
it and i i think it's funny but it's
only funny when they start singing
you know when they sing or they make
poop jokes yeah yeah yeah because they
do that as well yeah the poop jokes
because most of their references are so
obscure i don't understand the humor
but that's another one that sandra ought
to look at is the [ __ ]
mst 3000 the newer ones on uh
netflix she'd probably like those yeah
she could sit around eat peanut butter
eating peanut butter making peanut
butter pie actually they just added
mystery science theater the movie
um i think they just added it on hulu i
want to say
oh another thing sanders that jenny
jenny did a damn investigation on your
uh [ __ ] mcduffin [ __ ] peanut
butter what's that [ __ ] called miss
gillan
nick skill and what was the name of that
[ __ ] kennedy mechanic no
there's a blog that i read a food blog
that i read called the take out the
candy
um there was coincidentally an article
that just went up
like yesterday or the day before and it
was about
uh a woman who's american but she's
lived in berlin
for 10 years and she was talking about
you know going to a german grocery store
and sampling like
american style food that they sell in
germany which is like
in no way shape or form like american
food yeah it's not it's not correct
that's kind of happened in the uk too i
noticed but not to such an extent but
um i did see and this has been a while
but i did see some stuff when i was in
the uk that was like hey american style
this and i'm like what the [ __ ] are they
talking about i just don't even know
yeah
there was a there was some something
british i had something british that was
supposed to be
like a louisiana-style sauce or
something so it was in egypt
all right the [ __ ] the british army
[ __ ] said it to us
and uh it didn't taste anything like you
anything from louisiana
yeah i think it might have been
louisiana hot sauce or something i was
like no that's not it
that's wrong yeah as interpreted by
the limeys uh now evidently mckennedy uh
peanut butter is like
passable it's like yeah well according
to the woman that wrote this
who was an american and she said this is
actually a pretty decent period it's not
quite as good as like
you know american people as jiff or
something but um
you see it's like it's it's passable
right you're gonna want jiff
yeah peanut butter junkie like her she
wants jiff
peter pan or skippy
damn damn yeah let's get it they're all
a little bit different they're all a
little bit different
but those are all popular here
smuckers too smucker's peanut butter
they like smuckers
it has to be good yeah they won't get
the reference
maybe some people might shut up
yeah pat says she may be a nerd but
she's an attractive nerd thank you very
much
uh scott says mst is a great cultural
education it certainly is it makes you
because if there's a reference on there
i don't understand i'm like i wonder
what that means and so then i go look it
up and then it's a whole like rabbit
hole
which is kind of neat yeah pluto has an
mst channel they also have a rifftrax
channel actually when i was on vacation
in my uh
in my little airbnb room i just left the
mst
pluto channel just playing all the time
[Laughter]
you know what i mean just while i was
doing other [ __ ] and so it seemed like
somebody was
yeah because they i mean they've done so
many so many episodes
but uh yeah scott said i remember that
ad see i knew there would be some person
that was it wasn't that long ago jesus
christ
yeah so so you have these two yeah we
went off on the on the nerd tangent
because
because i said clive and elsa because
immediately i was just like oh bride of
frankenstein i mean colin clive played
frankenstein in the first frankenstein
too but he also played him in
bride of frankenstein and of course elsa
lanchester also played brandon
frankenstein
in the the titular role in that movie
so uh so these two are genetic
engineers and they make
these two um dick monster dick creatures
they look like dicks i mean come on um
they're
i love how the wikipedia page calls them
vermiform
which means you know worm shaped but
they're totally dicks seriously
uh and they call them fred and ginger
now they
these what old uh dna was mixed in with
this it was i remember they had like the
little animals on the on the doohickey
that said like what all the
animals were that went into these into
the dick monsters
but i can't remember what animals they
were but it was like a whole bunch of
different ones
and they were developing these creatures
for what because they secreted something
and they were making drugs with them
yeah that's what i was thinking so kind
of drugs and enzymes and stuff you can
make medicine out of them
yeah it was a drug company basically
yeah that they were working for
fallout
where they were kind of like going like
that i'm just like am i
supposed to be watching this yeah i need
a shower now
they look like they look like a couple
of chubbies
crawl along the floor yeah
like i said this is like like it's so
crazy
[Laughter]
yeah yeah should be the size of a damn
chicken
yeah so sanders in there goes what is it
chubby
chubby they don't have chubbies in
germany
by the way she said that she said that
uh she bought more of that mckinney
mckinney peanut butter
yeah she's got a whole stock of it she's
hoping that it's good
she think according to that woman it's
that american woman
i'll have to find that like yeah yeah
she said
i think she the word cheese was decent
she said
i think that was so original i just i
thought it was so funny because we were
talking about it and then i saw that
article pop
up and i'm like oh how fortuitous so i
went in there i read it
yeah but everything some of the [ __ ] in
there was hilarious evidently european
interpretations of american food is just
shitty
you know or strange just wrong yeah like
we're like we don't do that the textures
will be wrong the flavors will be
wrong you know just one of my favorite
things
that they had was kind of like a pizza
slash burger slash bagel
yeah i can't even it's like i'm looking
at it going what
even is that yeah
and you'd be you'd be you'd be really
surprised
if you american people would be very
it's
very surprising to go to other countries
and see what they call a hamburger bond
brazil had something that that they said
was a hamburger bun that is not a
hamburger bun
it was shaped like one but the texture
was more like shortcake
muffin that's a little weird like a
muffin yeah
real [ __ ] although not gonna lie i'd
probably eat it like sure that was on
yeah muffin muffin or biscuit yeah a
biscuit more like a biscuit
i would eat that which an american
biscuit not a british biscuit yeah
because those are two yeah things that's
more like in other words
like a scone yeah like a scone
yeah that'd be the burger scone yeah
like a burger scone
yeah scones are good with uh strawberry
jam and clotted cream on there
yeah hamburger buns let's say light and
fluffy blueberry burgers
yeah it's that kind of [ __ ] yeah well
it's like i guess that
um one of the grocery stores in germany
i guess it's
uh it's little you know lidl however we
pronounce that
um i guess they have like an
quote-unquote american week
and then they like have so they have a
sale like on all of the american
style products and so she went there and
she like bought a bunch of them and she
was like taste testing
all of them and like some of them like a
couple of them were normal-ish but like
a lot of them are like super weird
yeah it's like we don't um we don't eat
hot dogs from a jar no yeah a hot dog
from a jar
that was [ __ ] astounding i have never
seen that ever i've never seen that ever
yeah
here and i'm not saying it doesn't exist
i'm just saying everywhere i've lived
i've never seen that i've never heard of
that i've never heard of that
uh no the only you know like you know
those little pickled sausages they're
like
served with the [ __ ] pickled pigs
feet the little red ones you buy yeah
[ __ ] redneck dime store yeah that's
the only thing i've ever seen
that's i've seen that and like vienna
sausages they sell them in like a little
canyon
yeah like a little can but those are
like a little bitty yeah and giant jars
are [ __ ]
almost a giant glass barrel of pickled
hard-boiled eggs
remember those yeah i haven't seen those
in forever i think all that shit's out
of style now i mean
although somebody once told me like i
thought they were making it up
but apparently there is a type of brown
bread that you buy in a can but i don't
think they sell it down here it's but
it's either canadian thing or it's like
a kind of a upper midwest type of thing
great brown bread in a can yeah it's
well it's because you can
you can ship it easily it doesn't crush
yeah
uh but yeah so again we got distracted
because because we were talking about
like chubby dick monsters
yeah so uh so they're making drugs that
is the company that they work for
and so clive and elsa are like
we need to do some like human
experimentation we want to jump right to
that i'm like didn't you see
frankenstein didn't you see it i said
you it never ends well and this really
really doesn't end well holy crap
this goes in like some really [ __ ] up
directions
so they decide well we're gonna then the
company's like no absolutely not
and so they're like we're just gonna do
it on the sly then
uh so they decide they're going to mix
together
a whole bunch of dna i don't know
specifically why they chose the
creatures that they chose i think there
was a kangaroo in there there was like
some kind of wing i think there might
have been a plant in there too somewhere
and then they said we're gonna throw
some human dna in there too because why
not
um and i think originally doesn't
they don't say oh it's an anonymous
female donor uh
but it's turns out not so anonymous yeah
it's the girls
yeah it's hers yeah um spoiler alert but
yeah so
they have this uh you know the creature
comes out
and it kind of looks like at first it
kind of looks like a weird
bunny chicken something it's got it's
got
long legs two just two legs doesn't have
any arms
kind of like a big chick yeah it did
kind of look like that but it didn't
really have
yeah it was like kind of without any fur
or anything it was
just skin and it had a head kind of like
a bunny rabbit
without any ears yeah yeah eyes on
either side of its head and it could
look like
but it grew rapidly they looked at the
cells
and um just one day of its life was like
weeks wouldn't it
weeks yeah something like that because i
think she grew to like well she was
she grew into kind of like a baby size
like a toddler size and she had a tail
and stuff and she started looking like
more
more human human yeah but then it was
only like a month or two
and she was like fully grown like a
fully grown person yeah for a while
she was like uh like a like a six year
or seven-year-old they had her in a
little dress
and her feet were kind of like an
animal's feet where they're running on
their tiptoes and the
and the foot part of the foot is real
long like a cat's back leg
yeah she had that with the tail skin
and her head still kind of it looked
human but the eyes were way spaced out
and couldn't talk just made clicks and
chirps and
you know kind of like animal noises but
it could spell it learned to spell with
the blocks yeah it was like really
understand it was real intelligent and
uh then it grew to like the size of a
teenager in
a few weeks huh mm-hmm and they had to
hide it they got to get it out of the
laboratory because it's people are going
to find it
and find out and one guy does see is the
dude's brother sees it you know what i
mean he didn't approve this [ __ ]
they put it in a box and rolled it out
to the car and took it out to the girl's
mom's farm and the mama died
and they keeping it in the in the farm
out there
in the barn now at one time
there's this at one time there's uh it
it almost died when it was out there
they didn't know what was wrong with it
he put it in the water and looked like
he was trying to drown it to get it out
of its misery
but then it started coughing underneath
the water and started breathing the
water
yeah and it got better it turned out it
was an amphibian it
it had to have water to go into to um
to breathe every night had to use its
lungs and its
um gills it didn't really have gills it
was like an internal gill
yeah it had to use both of them her name
was dren by the way which is nerds
nerds nerd yeah because that was the
name of the company thing they worked
for the or the research thing they
worked for
and uh it becomes pretty unruly its tail
ended up having a damn
poison like a scorpion type action on
the end there
yeah and it was intelligent that wanted
to go outside
well yeah and it was it had human
intelligence so it's like you can't
really keep her
you couldn't really keep her locked up
like that had human intelligence and a
lot of ant
to human intelligence but it had a lot
of animal instincts and it wasn't very
old
but it grew to to be a teenager and i
guess a matter of months
yeah i think because i think the whole
movie takes place only
over like a month or two yeah right and
like it so it grows up
and it's it's [ __ ] up because at first
clive is kind of like man we shouldn't
be doing this this was a mistake we need
to kill it
um so and that was kind of his thing but
elsa
who i guess she um i think they they
kind of imply too that she had like an
abusive
mom right because i feel like her mom
died i think they bring that up a couple
times yeah and she's a bit of a psycho
actually
yeah and she is actually she she's kind
of like
she's kind of like the dr frankenstein
of the story yeah because she
um wants to keep the keep dren
and she starts treating her like a kid
right um like it's her kid like yeah
instead of like an experiment and clive
was like man this is really not gonna
go well because this is not you know um
he
he thinks they should destroy it because
it's getting out of control you know
what i mean
yeah what's the woman's name again do
you remember the woman's name
the actress or the character the
character elsa elsa that's right yeah
like brighter pranks
yeah elsa is kind of a [ __ ] because
the the creature dread it it it adopted
a cat
you know which is like its only
companion and she took the cat away from
him yeah from her
it's like she's [ __ ] crazy you know
if you ask me yeah she was a nutcase
she's not i'll just get you sick you
know what i mean and i think it's
because
her mom was that way to her um yeah i
think that's what they were implying was
that she was trying not to be like her
mom like she wanted to have a kid but
she couldn't help it because it was kind
of like that's the way she'd been
brought up and she didn't
yeah she didn't know any different or
she didn't really got all it got
it got rebellious and
later on she gives the uh the cat back
and out of spite draen [ __ ] stabs it
with her tail and kills the cat
like [ __ ] you see i can't watch that
yeah i can't watch
well she was just happening she wasn't a
human i know
that's that's part of the thing well she
had
animal instincts you know she wasn't
very old you know she's like i said a
month old or so
maybe maybe two months and uh
elsa freaks out [ __ ] straps her down
onto an operating table and cuts that
stinger out of her
without indiana i guess there was a
little bit of anesthesia yeah i think
she did give her
um although she was kind of like
thrashing around yeah
and dude comes in [ __ ] sees it's like
what the [ __ ] is this you know what are
you doing you know
he was having he started to decide with
draen about you know have some
compassion for this
creature yeah because previously he was
just like it's just an experiment we
need to get rid of it we're going to get
in trouble we're going to jail this is
super illegal which it is
right uh but i think i think that was
kind of like the
the point at which he started to like
you said side with dren against his
girlfriend yeah and um
so because of that dren starts
have having like a serious crush on the
dude she's drawing pictures of him and
everything you know
and she's like hiding the pictures a
little crayon pictures and [ __ ]
and um while the while
uh elsa was away this thing [ __ ] base
he's dancing with her
because she is [ __ ] sad she wanted to
go outside
so he put it on put the record on and
he's dancing with her and he's
looking at her and he's dawned on in
this she looks just like elsa
yeah and he's like oh man this is elsa's
dna that [ __ ] put their own dna in this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
and yeah and it's it's the
the creature you know trend it's cute
it's got a cute face it looks a little
bit
like an alien it's eyes are kind of
spaced out a little too far it doesn't
have any hair
um it's got
weird legs like a like a cat but only
like
a total of four fingers or three fingers
at a thumb
and it's the same on its feet it's got a
thumb back there and
yeah three fingers they're long she's
weird looking but i could totally see
how some people be like yeah i'd hit
that yeah
she's kind of kind of kinky looking you
know and it's got a tail
and and she's like physically superior
she can just jump like a cat you know at
one point
at one point like she has she's like oh
i have wings now
yeah well she almost fell off the roof
and then pat wings popped out of this
out of these slits that she could close
up which
in her arms and on her back yeah it's a
trip
and she could hang upside down by her
feet and
maybe jump 20 feet i think she could run
on all fours too couldn't she
did she i think she could yeah yeah that
actress that plays her
uh she's french her name's delphine
shania
yeah and um they i have to say the
special effects in this because this is
like
several years old it's from 2009 the
special effects in this are
amazing yeah they look really really
good and this wasn't a huge i think this
movie cost like 26 million to make
yeah um it didn't do all that well at
the theater but it got like good uh
reviews and stuff
so eventually what happens is is that
this creature [ __ ] seduces this dude
man she puts the [ __ ] moves on him
i think it's sexually aggressive and
he's just a man what's he going to do
well yeah well i don't think there was
any resist in that anyway i think i
think she might have been stronger than
him huh
uh yeah well i yeah because the [ __ ]
that she was doing she would have to be
yeah
and she just put the moves on him and
she was funny she could stand on she
could stand on the ground one
with one leg and then the other leg
reach up behind her grab on to something
and she's pulling him in
trying to [ __ ] pull him into that
[ __ ] whirlpool
that's gonna hit him with that whirlpool
and uh
she throws him down on the ground and
starts taking his clothes off with all
four limbs
[ __ ] he's like whoa what the [ __ ]
she's on top actually
i have the weirdest they're rolling
around and it's
and it took his shirt off with her back
foot reached up behind him and took his
shirt off and
he's like what the [ __ ] and then she
gets on top of him and starts cowgirling
the [ __ ] out
just [ __ ] cowgirl you know what i'm
talking about and [ __ ] the wings are
popping out you know yeah during all
that [ __ ]
guess who comes in his girlfriend
what the [ __ ] yeah i'm [ __ ] awesome
you know
[Laughter]
hey you know it's a little hard to
explain yeah you know
it's not what it looks like no that's
exactly what it looks like yeah so she's
and then she's like you crossed the line
there and i was like he's like well it's
not like we're still little
it's not like we're married you know
yeah it doesn't make me gay or anything
it is female you know just kind of [ __ ]
like that you know
it's kind of funny if you ask me you
know but anyway
this [ __ ] this this dread is like
[ __ ] in love with this dude
a bunch of other stuff happens uh
turns out that bugging it kind of starts
getting
sick and it dies
and they bury it and then while he's
getting busted
it didn't die it was metamor it had a
metamorphosis and it came up out of the
ground
but it came up out of the ground as a
male yeah because that's what happened
to those other ones
to the dick monsters the little dick
monsters because yeah one should change
into it from a female to a bigger flip
and then they started like fighting
sexual flipping flipping
they flipped one way and they flap
another flip-flop
[Laughter]
and she flip-flopped came out
and then it you see it it it thought
that that
that it thought that it had been
betrayed from what i remember
yeah i think that's what it was because
they buried it so
like it was pissed off yeah and um
it it attacked him and then it grabbed
the woman
and it [ __ ] raped the woman yeah
because it's a boy now yeah
it raped her and he [ __ ] runs up on
it stabs it but it
it hit him with the tail and [ __ ]
poisoned him didn't it yeah it was with
the tail right yeah
either that or like it went right in his
heart or whatever but it's like either
way they both died
but the woman lived and then they're
showing her
back at the damn bio lab and she they're
giving her a huge
check for [ __ ] millions and millions
of dollars to keep quiet
and to give them the rights on [ __ ]
what she's gonna what she's bringing
into the world and you look and she's
[ __ ]
yeah the monster got this [ __ ] she's
pregnant and you imagine what the [ __ ]
i would be like terrified terrifying
enough having a human baby it's like you
don't know what the [ __ ] gonna come
out of there they want
they wanted to use the uh
the the offspring as a as a
as a drug-making machine basically they
were talking about all the
all the enzymes and the weird proteins
that it was making
they'd be able to [ __ ] uh all their
research was coming to fruition
through this thing and then that's how
the movie ends so they kind of leave it
open for a sequel
although i think vincenzo natali because
i think he wrote this as well and he was
just kind of like you know yeah we could
have made a sequel but he's like he
didn't really want to and i don't think
that um
this made enough money to justify like i
said it got decent reviews
but it didn't make i think it just
barely made its budget back
yeah um it's i think it's like a
partially
canadian partially french movie so it's
not like
an american production company yeah but
um
yeah i don't i don't even think it made
its budget back
who said is this on netflix uh no we saw
it on amazon i don't think it was on
netflix
it's either on amazon you can rent it on
youtube i think it's 2.99 yeah and i
think it's
it's 299 on on amazon also i think it is
it's worth seeing
it's good movies it definitely is if you
like like genetic engineering and it's
uh
and it's beautifully beautifully shot
like the cinematography is really nice
yeah it's got good
uh uh good score good acting the guy the
dude who plays the the the dude who
plays the dude the guy who plays the guy
the guy with the guy with the head and
the dude
with the face yeah
it's the same guy from do with the face
you know
the the uh it's the same guy from
predators
predators yeah adrian brody he's been in
tons and tons of stuff he actually
did he what he win an oscar he was i
know he's been dominated several times
no scott there wasn't any anal no well
not that they showed anyway
but it's just kind of like it's such a
[ __ ] up idea
i think a lot of people like when i saw
like because i saw some reviews of it
and a lot of people like really liked it
but they thought
that um the scene where he ends up
having sex with dren
was too unbelievable because they said
it wasn't um
it didn't really like lead up to it
enough like because prior to that
uh clive had been kind of like no this
is we shouldn't be doing this we're
gonna get in trouble we need to kill it
we need to do this that the other thing
but like you said i think there was a
point where um
he saw her more as a person because she
was kind of strapped down to the table
and he was just like and i think at that
point he
got more like uh sympathetic toward her
than he was toward his girlfriend
and like you said you know she was
pretty uh aggressive
yeah she wasn't gonna take no from that
for an answer and they end like i said
she had uh elsa's dna so and he
presumably found elsa hot because you
know they were dating
so you know [ __ ] happens uh
[ __ ] happens you're just one day you're
just dancing with a mutant genetic
engineer
animal person and then you know
he wasn't really given a choice really
that's true you know what i mean that
was just
that was how women raped men
come over here well she had
she had [ __ ] both she had one hand
she had her leg grabbing a damn pole
behind her
then she had other hand on him and then
the other leg grip
and just it she could move in a way that
that human couldn't move
she was super strong i mean they showed
her jumping
making leaps of at least 30 feet like
something that a jaguar would do so she
was at least as strong as a jaguar
yeah or yeah when you when you talk
about the weight she's probably about
120 pounds
i would say and yeah you're talking
about
a big cat type strength
yeah yeah i [ __ ] i i dare you i
challenge any man
to go fight a 35 pound bobcat you're
gonna get [ __ ] up
you're gonna get [ __ ] up
you even think something that small can
[ __ ] you up that bobcat will [ __ ] you up
and imagine what a hundred pound [ __ ]
little puma can do
you know well hell all right poison
tails
she had a poison tail yeah that's
another [ __ ] that she could like sling
around and
like poison you yeah yeah well [ __ ] i
was gonna say our
little uh beijing who is what maybe 11
12 pounds
if that yeah uh she puts you in the
hospital for for a week yeah
just for the damn bite they got a bite
damn
filthy ass [ __ ] infection bite yeah
there's little needle teeth you know the
the wound closes back up just sealing
all the damn
all that venom in there it's like venom
i mean if
if a cat was mad at you and jumped on
your head you'd be in big trouble
but that but dren could hang
upside down from from a rafter
on one foot remember that yeah yeah
grip it with one foot like a monkey so
that takes a lot of strength
yeah so you know and then she unfolded
herself and
came down so she was kind of
intimidating when you looked out that
way physically
yeah she could like she could kill you
yeah big time
yeah which that ended up happening
basically it killed him
she killed pretty much everybody i think
then did she kill the brother too
like did she kill his brother yeah she
killed him first yeah that's what i
thought and she could do it on the wing
when she was flying
she'd fly around at night like a bat
just soar down
get you it's a crazy movie it's crazy
it kind of like i said it's kind of
cronenbergian uh it
had a little bit of the fly i felt like
it had kind of that sort of thing
especially with the that scene where
gina davis
dreams that she gives birth to a maggot
yeah you know that whole thing
yeah during that final attack it was
doing things kind of purportedly of what
the mothman would do
it's kind of like mothman remember they
were standing on top of the house and
swooped down
all that kind of [ __ ] we've solved the
mystery dread
[Laughter]
yeah oracle said we had a cat named
willow maybe about eight pounds soaking
wet but she had attitude to spare she
once took on three of our other cats and
one damn
[Laughter]
yeah i mean you know yeah yeah or
chimpanzee
uh danny rolling ghostface said i wonder
what was bigger drones peter or dren's
[ __ ]
yeah they never really showed it did
they didn't they didn't show
i mean some of the some of the sex
scenes in this were like fairly graphic
but not
you know porny graphic sandra mentioning
that i want to fight an alligator you're
right
um i said jenny man we got to get the
camera
and um you got to you got to get me
[ __ ] i'll dress up i'll [ __ ] put
my [ __ ] best jungle [ __ ] outfit on
your junk you juggle [ __ ] yeah i put
my [ __ ] put my
jungle [ __ ] outfit that's when i [ __ ]
jungles
i'm just gonna say everyone those times
when you're gonna go out and [ __ ]
juggle
i'll put my vietnam tiger camouflage
tiger stripe camo on there
and uh so you get a video of me [ __ ]
uh
catching an alligator you know i'll get
like a five foot or a six footer
pull them out of the water i can do it
yeah i can do it i know how to do it
i'll just i'll just stay well away and
then uh
if you get eaten then it'll go uh viral
i'm like maybe i'll make a bunch of
money yeah see i'll keep him around five
feet because he won't
he won't be able to eat me well you
might like lose a hand or something no
i know you got to get up behind him and
[ __ ] grab his grab his mouth well
yeah sure
because they can't they can't it's hard
to open it yeah and then once you get
and then you gotta
you gotta straddle their head so the
tail can't whap you
and then you gotta [ __ ] pull him up
out of the water if you go for anything
that's really big
if they get a hold of you they'll pull
you down in the water you'll drown uh
yeah so
you know but i'll study it
and i'll study how it's done perfectly
my dad used to be able to do it yeah but
i've actually never done it so that's
gonna say that would be a great story of
parties
not very big ones though you know five
six well yeah i mean you would be
she would look cool on film man it would
but alligator you know
yeah i got him you know yeah
that said yeah i also want to see the
video of you fighting it yeah
you fight an alligator i'll put on one
of their [ __ ] strongman outfits
with the ones thing that goes down it'd
be like a leopard print [ __ ] a strong
man
oh there you go
oh my goodness yeah oh i guess willow
see catfish noodling is not gonna
impress anybody well you know
they're gonna ever you know a girl can
can noodle you know
a girl canoe
yeah it's not a good idea to do it by
yourself reach in there in the damn snap
and turtle get you and you ah
you can't pull them out the hole you
drown or one of those like big hell
catfish like [ __ ] jeremy wade catches
yeah that can like swallow your whole
head yeah no thank you
i gotta do some [ __ ] hardcore redneck
[ __ ]
i'm gonna put my bow back there too i
got my bow yeah why don't you
you could go work at the alligator farm
in saint augustine yeah they might let
you they
they don't do uh they don't do wrestling
no
and i think but i think if those
alligators like i said if they got mad
enough at you one day because there's no
way you could get away from them because
there's so many of them in there
if somebody fell in you would be like
really really [ __ ] yeah
really funny now i got to get a video of
me fighting something
let's just see this testosterone yeah
yeah i'm gonna give you some fight some
man it's it's
gonna be it's gonna be a long uh however
many years until i die
i gotta i gotta you gotta get me on
video fighting it
and it can't be something that'll send
me to jail
[Laughter]
so it can't be a person
[Laughter]
might go to jail if there's a person
tammy says i don't give a
[ __ ] about going to jail just it just
costs too much goddamn money
yeah and they put that on there you know
simple battery that's you know
tammy said that i need to buy you an
alligator pool float to practice on
hey birthday gift idea
scott says there was an alligator place
on i-4 between orlando and daytona where
they did wrestling i don't remember
i know there was but i don't remember
where it was i'll break into that [ __ ]
and jenny will be with me and we'll do
experimental alligator wrestling i'll
just figure it out as i go
and she can get it on louis said don't
you guys have bears yeah you could fight
there
although the bears will run well the
bears around here are kind of like
what what no they're not being when they
run they run
they're just like i don't like this not
one minute i just came here to like open
your fridge and get some beer
fastest way to get rid of a bear pear is
to call it every time i see a bear i
call it hey man what's up come on over
here and they go
oh yeah come on man where you going oh
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here and
then if i can
jump up on the fence and pull them steps
over the fence
remember that yeah if i pulled himself
over the fence
[Music]
poor little guy yeah he wasn't a real
big one he was kind of like a little
teenage size bear
we've seen like big giant ones around
here but yeah oh yeah
like that i've seen once we drove home
one time there's he was sitting in our
driveway
yeah where my car would normally yeah i
pulled in and
he's in the headlights and he goes oh
[ __ ] he leans over and gets up and walks
away
oh [ __ ] well i guess i gotta go to
another house anymore
yeah god damn it i got all comfy yeah
yes sandra said i watched the alligator
video with those huge birds that
alligator wasn't very
brave but it was only a baby yeah it
wasn't like a what a baby baby but it
was probably like
i don't know how like alligators live a
long time i guess so i don't know how
long it takes them to get to like
i got a video right here on this laptop
that that they sent me from mexico
of an alligator coming up out of the
water with a woman in his mouth
and then he swims away with a woman you
guys want to see it
no yeah she it drowned her
they're just walking around they can't
eat you if you're big they can't really
eat you while you're fresh they got to
hide you and let you rot
a little bit and they'll guard you and
guard the body
it'll rot and kind of soften up and then
they'll pull pieces of it off and
swallow it
yeah saving that yeah for later so it
couldn't swallow her so it just carried
her around
until she got soft which is so she's got
clothes on
and she's in his mouth oh god and
they're taking a video of it
you know from the bridge the little foot
bridge
and they're going oh look at the woman
look at the one he's got a woman it's
got a woman you're saying in spanish
yeah [ __ ] man yeah yeah gatorland that's
what you're yeah that's right i think
that's still there
i guess yeah grampa's hammer said aren't
there millions of boa constrictors in
florida i don't know about millions but
there are like a lot of
them because a lot of people have had
them as pets and then they escape or
yeah you know something there's
anaconda's out here evidently there's
all kind of [ __ ]
yeah there was for a long time there was
a um
there was a little community of monkeys
i don't remember what kind of monkeys it
was though
because they had escaped from a zoo
someplace and then they just bread
because like i said florida
pretty much any animal that escapes from
anywhere uh is gonna be like oh it's all
like
wet and warm out here i'm just gonna
propagate there's a bunch of south
american fish that people have let go
that live here now like arapaima
live here and snakehead yeah live here
in florida
they're not supposed to be here there's
an invasive species yep
yeah what are you going to do yeah all
right do we have anything else we need
to know
because man i can't believe we went up
for almost an hour yeah we gotta go i'm
just like yeah i need a nap
like i said i'm not i you know we drank
a lot last night but it's like i don't
really get hangovers anymore but
the next day like right around three or
four o'clock i get super super sleepy
no all the nutrients are up in louisiana
that's louisiana yeah but they're
they're eating them
you can eat neutral so guys people are
starting to eat them and if you tell
cajuns that you that they're good to eat
and they're trying to that'll wipe them
out eventually
because that's [ __ ] well like i said
that show that gordon ramsay was doing
like that recent one yeah remember he
went there and he went on like the hunt
and then like he had like that guy's mom
had made like a stew out of them
yeah but because they give you like a
couple bucks
per like because you know they have they
have a
thing on them yeah and they're all over
the place so you i can't remember the
word that i'm trying to like think of
okay super tired scott florida bears
aren't small they're the same as any
other black bear
uh which which a black barefoot gets old
enough can get quite big yeah we've seen
like real big big ones yeah
but most of the ones you see are not big
ones they're young they're the young
ones
uh if they're [ __ ] around in
neighborhoods too long they don't they
tend not to get very old they get hit by
cars
they're allowed to get hit by cars or
animal control
kills them that's what usually the main
thing to do because there's no
shortage of them this idea that there's
that they're endangered no not at all
they're about like they're everywhere
they're everywhere they're about they're
about like uh
they're about like uh raccoons and those
are everywhere
yeah at least in florida raccoons
possums yeah raccoons
armadillos and they'll they'll walk into
a city you know they go [ __ ] it that's
where the food is you know that's where
all the people are let's go to that city
and then [ __ ] barrel walk into the
city looking for food
that's ridiculous as well that's why
that's why we have to have those garbage
cans with the elaborate
locking mechanism on the top because
they'll come and like
they figure out how to open regular
trash cans they're not a predator
they're they're an opportunist more like
a scavenger yeah they'll just go oh
garbage cans people hey how you doing
they don't like to
score pizza crusts yeah they'll steal
before they'll hunt
you know well it's easier it's a lot so
much easier they're lazy just like every
other species
they're not really made to chase
anything down and and
they're they don't kind of have
a lot of prey type animals to live off
they just dig [ __ ] up and
steal [ __ ] that died and [ __ ] going
to garbage cans and
you know yeah scott said they break into
suvs here all the time for candy bars
go in they'll go into a house yeah
they'll go into a house and go
open the fridge they know what a
refrigerator is they'll go right to the
refrigerator oh
food they got them on video just videos
[ __ ] on youtube they'll be rolling
around [ __ ] holding stuff in their
hands and eating it
calling the other ones [ __ ] funny
would it be if you got up in the middle
of the night to go get
something out of that there was a bear
just like standing there in front of the
fridge like looking for something to eat
that would be something yeah they all be
splayed out and [ __ ] with their feet all
splayed out and just [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah happy as [ __ ] oh man
ace this ac is nice i think he's gonna
live in here from now on
yeah just opening [ __ ] up because yeah
that's good you know
like a little kid scooping stuff out
yeah scooping out ice cream
yeah they'll let the other bears in this
videos have been doing that too
because they can they can open doors
yeah they'll let the other bears in
come on carl let's go yeah it's
ridiculous
they're so cute though yeah you can't be
mad they're just like looking for food
they're more intelligent than people
think they are oh yeah big time i think
i think a lot of animals are
yeah probably put a bear at close to a
chimpanzee it's just a different kind of
personality
imagine if a dog kind of had a lot of
intelligence
intelligence closer to a chimpanzee but
they're not quite as they don't think
they have them
the problem solving abilities of chimp
and it's a different personality but
similar yeah chimps are like hell beasts
yeah when you see
videos of candid shots of bears doing
what i was telling you going through
people's houses
you can definitely tell there's a
there's an intelligence there
they know what they're doing well yeah i
mean
i mean think about how complicated from
an animal's point of view how
complicated that
concept is of going inside a house and
like finding a refrigerator and opening
the refrigerator and all this other kind
of stuff they know they're stealing too
because when the people come they run
like
like they got caught they know they're
stealing
well it's just kind of like well even
even pookie if she's doing something
she's not supposed to be doing
yeah and you say something about it like
she looks at you like oh [ __ ] that's
right i'm not supposed to be doing it
she knows
she knows when she's not supposed to be
doing something yeah you yelled at her
this morning because she was scratching
on something she wasn't supposed to be
scratching on yeah i pointed at this
no and i pointed at the damn thing where
the damage was and she was oh [ __ ] and
rant
i just forgot for a second yeah see
everything's in the moment
yeah well she just likes to scratch and
sometimes she forgets she's not supposed
to scratch them
yeah all right so i guess we're gonna
wrap it up uh we'll be back tomorrow
probably talk about another movie i
already have one in mind
uh to watch tonight that we can talk
about tomorrow like i said i'm gonna go
uh get some coffee and then i'm gonna
take a nap because i'm really really
tired
uh so yeah you guys have a good rest of
your weekend thank you for dropping by
as always
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye